Ken, we need to film,
what are you doing?
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on.
>> You buying some tight kicks?
>> Yeah, and I'm just about done.
I can see that I just need to finish
my payment information and done.
>> Why don't you show
then what you just did?
>> Okay, all right, my phone wasn't
actually on because we're acting.
Come on we're filming.
Anyways.
[LAUGH] I just thought
this would be a good lead-in to
the feedback part of this lesson,
because it's all about showing
your users their progress.
>> I see,
you were buying something online and
the form was nice enough to show you
that you only had to finish paying.
>> Yeah, but my phone is off, so
why don't you show students
what this actually looks like?
>> Sounds good.